Liev Schreiber and Naomi Watts have  separated et can exclusively report the  couple is calling it quits after 11  years together the actors released a  joint statement telling et quote over  the past few months we've come to the  conclusion that the best way forward for  us as a family is to separate as a  couple it is with great love respect and  friendship in our hearts that we look  forward to raising our children together  and exploring this new phase of our  relationship the pair has two children  together  nine-year-old sasha and seven-year-old  kai earlier this month  Liev took Sasha as his date to the Emmys  what was it like getting ready today oh  one of the best days of my life so proud  to be here with Sasha  so proud of him and this is a great  night Naomi showed her support by  posting this photo of the duo getting  ready for the event in the caption she  wished her man good luck and Kush that  she was proud beyond words